όχι μεαδιατί είμαι οποταλα κάποιο σκερτούμε το προσωπικό που υπαρχική υποβάλλονται α το πω σε
παθαο αθανιστήρια να βλέπουν όλα αυτά δα ελικά που και πόσον πολλο να είσαι παντέρα
δημητέρα πόσο μάλλον να βλέπεις αυτά τα πράγματα υπήρχαν περιπτώσεις διοποί έρχουντανσυνέλφι και μου όλεγαν
αντεχω αλλο υτός είναιάροσ έχει ξεφύγειμουλεδιαδή υπάρχουν ανταυτείται νυπιακής ηλικίας παιδιά να κακοποιούνται είναι πραγματικά
κιο χαριστικών άλλον ν ακούσεις αλλά το χαιρότερο ενίναι α βλέπεις αυτό λεγώ είναι πολύ
δυσκολών και εγώ συχαίρωτα παιδιαική ατί είναι πολύ πενοσε πολύ ψυχοφθώρο αν διαδικασία να βλέπουν
όλα αυτά τ πράγματα και να προσπαθούν να είναιεντάξει ξεστημικογένεια τους καισαν ανθρώποιο γενικά είναι
σοχαριστικώ μεργες πονά οεσογάτι το σαχρομια π σια ξέρουν ποράμην ξέρωσε από τέ στην τηλεράστες
φορές τα φιλοξένησα το πώτικας μαζί είναι αυτή τη την άτα τι ήταν αυτό που
σου είπε κάποιος οσο έφεραν για ανάκριση και σε έβγαλε ναεκτώσι αυτό που ασχολίτουν με
την παιδική μπορνογράφεια πολύ δυσκχωρίς να στοχοποιούμενη υπόθεση χωρίς να ούτε χρονική περιόότι ήταν αυτό
που γύρισε κάποιος να πει που συνελήθε για παιαδική πορνογραφεία και σε εβγαλε νε κτό
ευτό ατο πό μια περίπτωσηνλλι ήταν να θαβατο απόγεμα με ειδοποιησαν από τογραφείο πρέπει να
ρθει το γραείο μεμλεγα της υδέτη πρέπει να αρχισ στο γραφείο δάξει πάωυτό αγροφήα τακτικά
πήγα κεί τογραφείο μου υπόδειξαν τριαπίτιο όπου ανήλικος είχε ερωτική επαφί με άλλο ανήλικο τ